الالوان والفن رحله الى عالم الجمال
والتذوق بعيدا عن مشاكل الحياه هتبات واحد
من احدث الاساليب العلاجيه على مستوى
العالم مجموعه من الباحثين في جماعه موسكو
الحكوميه للعلوم النفسيه والتربويه درسوا
تاثير العلاج بالفن على البالغين الذين
يعانون من انواع مختلفه من التوتر التي
يشعر بها الشخص بعد قراءه اخبار سلبيه او
التي تمتاز بالطلاب قبل الامتحانات بعد
سلسله من التجارب تبين انه في 90% من
الحالات ساعد الرسم والتفكير في الاشياء
الفنيه التي انشاهارون في تحييد القناه
العلاج بالفم بحسب الخبراء يمكن ان يكون
مفيده ليس فقط القلق ولكن ايضا لتحقيق
اهداف اخرى طويله المدى فمثلا تساعد دروس
الرسم المنتظمه البالغين على تحليل
تجاربهم على مستوى اللاوعي وكذلك تحسين
الذاكره وتصوير الخيال مما يزيد من
فعاليات اكتساب مهارات جديده
طرقت الجامعات المصريه اخيرا ابواب كلاش
بالفرن فقد اعلنت جامعه حلوان عن دبلوم
للعلاج بالفن فما هو العلاج بالفن وفقا
للجمعيه الامريكيه للعلاج بالفن فان هذا
العلاج يستخدم التواصل غير اللفظيه
للتعبير عن المشاعر والافكار يدعم العلاج
بالفم لاعتقاد بان كل شخص لديه القدره على
التعبير عن نفسه بشكل ابداعي ويختار
المعالج بالفن الاساليب الفنيه المناسبه
لتعكس حاله المريض العاطفيه العمليه
العلاجيه نفسها اكثر اهميه من النتيجه
النهائيه اذ يركز معالج على المتطلبات
العلاجيه للمريض للتعبير بدلا من المزايا
الجماليه للعمل الفني في 2015 قدم مستشفى
خمسه سبعه ثلاثه خمسه سبعه العلاج بالفن
والذي يعتمد على عدد من الفنون لتخفيف
الالم عن الاطفال المصابين بالسرطان
وتعديل الحاله النفسيه للطفل ووصلت حينها
نسبه النتائج الى 90%